what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we break down the most powerful
characters and comics now today we're
talking about a character who a lot of
you saw putting her powers on display in
the mcu the villain of thor ragnarok
hella but of course since this is comics
explained we're looking at the comic
version of hella who was created by stan
lee and jack kirby and first appeared in
journey into mystery number 102 in 1964
and is way more powerful than the movie
version so like most of the characters
that make up the thor mythos in marvel
comics hella was adapted from norse
mythology and like the norse myth she
was based on hella is the daughter of
loki not the loki that currently exists
in the marvel universe but one from a
previous version of aggar that was
destroyed in a cycle of ragnarok but
hella was born in yotenheim the realm of
the giants and her mother is strangely
enough the mother of monsters in norse
mythology now when she gets older odin
appoints hella to be the goddess of the
dead and gives her dominion over health
a realm which is home to the souls of
the dead now even though the name sounds
like it should be a realm of torture
it's really more of just a resting place
and its appearance can be changed to
anything that hella wishes but the realm
of hell also includes valhalla which is
a place of honor for the souls of the
bravest noblest and most heroic
asgardians and is also used to contain
elysium which was the resting place for
angels of heaven although recently
odin's daughter angela was able to usurp
hela's role of that region but the realm
of valhalla although physically located
in hell is not actually under hela's
control but is itself ruled by odin
however hella has tried on more than one
occasion to rest it from his control and
since her introduction into comics hell
has basically been one of the most
frequent adversaries of both thor and
his father odin now the list of hela's
powers is incredibly lengthy as she is
technically a giant because her parents
are both giants she also seems to have a
lot of physical characteristics and
abilities of an asgardian even though
she isn't really as guardian at all at
any rate she possesses enhanced physical
attributes including strength durability
stamina speed and agility hell has been
able to trade punches with thor and has
even been able to knock him off his feet
in battle as for her durability she
survived hits from characters like moon
dragon and beta ray bill without
sustaining any injuries whatsoever now
hella is also highly skilled in combat
having bested some formidable opponents
in combat including thor valkyrie and
angela now hella is made even more
formidable by her weapon of choice than
knight sword which she can access at any
time and which was strong enough to
impale gladiator who himself has an
insane level of durability now the
knight sword was also strong enough to
cut through
exceedingly durable armor and injured
thor so badly that iron man remarked it
was the worst injury he'd ever seen thor
sustain although at that point i don't
think gore had been around gore
definitely tuned up thor more than hella
did but regardless
i love the thor god of thunder run by
jason aaron but hella's powers go way
beyond her physical prowess as she's
also extremely advanced in magical
abilities which she can use in a wide
variety of ways for example she can
channel her mystical energy into
powerful blasts that are capable of
disarming thor from mjolnir hello was
also able to deflect spells from dr
strange during the time that he was the
sorcerer supreme and we're talking about
like the original pre-retcon doctor
strange who could basically do anything
he wanted to he was just so ridiculously
overpowered that he boarded on
omnipotence and had to basically have
his powers reduced just so they could
tell stories about him so the fact that
not only could hell deflect his spells
but could also manipulate them as she
did when she influenced one of his
teleportation spells so that he
unwittingly ended up in hell shows us
that she's able to perform magic at an
exceedingly high level she was also able
to counteract one of mephisto's
enchantments when she reduced the size
of a wall of fire that he'd created on
another occasion hella was able to sense
the presence of loki which is really
impressive considering his whole deal is
basically being able to sneak around and
deceive people but he wasn't really able
to do that with hella hella also uses
her magical abilities to alter the
environment around her which we already
alluded to when discussing how the realm
of hell can be changed at a whimp now
just to get an idea of what she can do
to manipulate the environment around her
she can immerse an area several miles in
diameter in total darkness or she can
create enormous buildings
instantaneously she has caused the realm
of valhalla to tilt spilling out several
souls into health and was able to cast a
spell that would separate valhalla from
asgard where it was once located and
then relocated to help she was also able
to imbue her sword with enough magical
ability to pierce the protective spells
that protect odin while he's in the odin
sleep which if you didn't know odin has
to take a nap every once in a while to
restore his mystical energies and he's
extremely vulnerable in this state so
the asgardians protect him with powerful
enchantments now according to odin's
grandfather hela's sword also would have
been able to cut down idris sill the
world tree that links the nine realms
now since she is a master of death hella
is able to speed up the aging process
and was able to cause balder the brother
of thor to age rapidly as well as bring
thor himself to the point that he almost
died of old age which is really
impressive when you consider that thor
can live for thousands of years she also
displays mastery over souls and was able
to take a part of odin's soul and turn
it into an entity known as infinity that
was able to destroy planets at will so
if ever there was an argument against
hella being beyond omega level that
should basically put an end to it not
only can she steal part of the soul of
odin but she turned it into a
planet-destroying cosmic entity she also
nearly stole the soul of franklin
richards one of marvel's most powerful
reality warpers but of course her spell
was interrupted before she could finish
it now according to hala she perceives
all of space and time simultaneously
because there is no time or space where
death does not hold sway she can also
teleport characters as powerful as thor
balder and loki across realms against
their will and was able to send loki
back in time now as the goddess of death
hella is able to summon and control the
dead that reside within her realm on one
occasion she sent a multitude of the
dead to fight against the hulk and the
ensuing battle lasted for days and she
still had not used up all the souls at
her disposal she was able to bend the
cosmic ghost rider to her will because
as someone who was technically dead she
had complete control over him in
addition to these souls hella also has
other creatures she commands such as
fenris the wolf a large just contingent
of trolls and giant spiders and the
hellhound that guards the gates of a
realm in fact hella's forces have proved
formidable enough to destroy the
valkyries of asgard so yeah the power
level of hella as we saw her in the mcu
isn't really exaggerated at all compared
to her comic book counterpart and in
fact her comic book version is stronger
than the version that you saw in the mcu
just imagine that everything she did in
the marvel cinematic universe amplified
that about 10 times over and that's how
powerful she is in the comics she's on a
whole different level so with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end make sure you leave a
comment for anybody you want to see
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace